ils seront nos citoyens pour toujours la
déclaration de Vladimir Poutine le
président russe qui a signé le
rattachement de quatre régions
ukrainiennes à la Russie c'était il y a
quelques minutes ce après la tenue d'un
référendum dans ces zones on va écouter
d'abord un extrait de la prise de parole
du président russe
vous savez que dans les républiques
populaires de Daniel hogans dans les
oblastes
ont eu lieu des référendums
et nous avons calculé les résultats nous
connaissons le résultat de ces
référendums les gens ont fait leur choix
et ce choix est sans équivoque
aujourd'hui nous signons les accords
de ces territoires à la Russie voilà
pour ce discours de Vladimir Poutine
Bruno Darou bonjour vous êtes notre
spécialiste des questions
internationales on a quand même une
impression de déjà-vu ça rappelle la
journée du 18 mars 2014 lorsque la
Russie a été annexée par la Crimée c'est
une cérémonie qui est un peu en
copier-coller oui sur la forme c'est un
copier-coller puisque c'est il s'agit de
valider en quelque sorte une annexion
mais enfin bon les contextes sont quand
même très différents il y avait pas eu
de combat véritablement en Crimée et
puis il y avait plus une véritable
adhésion d'une majorité de la population
en Crimée au fait de rejoindre la Russie
pour des pour des raisons historiques
mais enfin effectivement les deux
cérémonies se ressemblent ce qui est
intéressant même dans l'extrait qu'on a
qu'on a entendu c'est que voilà bien
Poutine en fait il justifie en fait
cette annexion par le fait que
finalement c'est pas la Russie tellement
qui veut ça ce sont ces peuples ces 4
millions de personne comme il dit qui
ont voulu absolument rejoindre la Russie
lors d'un référendum et il faut
respecter leurs droits et il parle à ce
moment-là
du droit des peuples à
l'autonétermination qui effectivement
est inscrit dans les règles des Nations
Unies donc il dit il n'y a rien de mal à
tout ça enfin comme s'il ne comprenait
pas très bien l'indignation que cela
provoque à l'étranger donc du coup il
déroule comme ça tout son justificatifs
allant même dans un geste un peu de
magnanimité à s'adresser aux Ukrainiens
en leur disant ben écoutez maintenant si
vous voulez qu'on arrête la guerre c'est
le feu qu'on retourne à la table des
négociations j'y suis prêt mais
sous-entendu par contre comme ces
populations se sont exprimées librement
dit-il et bien moi je ne peux pas la
Russie ne peut pas les trahir ils ont
fait leur choix donc ça veut dire
clairement c'est c'est le feu et
négociation avec l'Ukraine mais pour que
l'Ukraine reconnaisse que ces
territoires ce qui représentent quand
même un cinquième du territoire
ukrainien fait désormais partie de la
Russie ce qui évidemment est
inacceptable pour les Ukrainiens la
cérémonie en grande pompe au Kremlin
parterre de personnalité
organisées dans le centre-ville de
Moscou mais sur le terrain la réalité
est totalement différente ces dernières
semaines les hommes de Vladimir Poutine
ont été de nombreuses défaites oui alors
c'est tout le paradoxe de la situation
et on peut même penser que Vladimir
Poutine a accéléré la tenue des
référendum à accélérer cette cérémonie
de validation des addictions précisément
parce que les soldats russes sont en
position difficile effectivement sur le
terrain confronté depuis le début du
mois de septembre à une offensive plutôt
très dynamique de l'armée ukrainienne à
Kerson autour de carquif et même dans la
république autoproclamée de Donetsk
puisque là les troupes ukrainiennes
seraient sur le point si on comprend
bien de s'emparer de la ville
stratégique de l'Imane qui se trouve
dans la République de Doni esk donc
évidemment il y a un côté un peu
fictionnel dans ce qu'annonce Vladimir
Poutine et c'est sans doute pour ça
qu'il a décidé d'aller très vite alors
après l'autre question qu'est-ce qui va
se passer maintenant bon visiblement lui
c'est assez intelligent et habile de sa
part se montre donc près à ouvrir des
négociations avec plus de tout en
sachant que les Ukrainiens vont refuser
mais il pourra se donner le beau rôle en
disant voyez moi je veux bien arrêter
cette guerre enfin ce sont les
Ukrainiens là qui qui ne le veulent pas
et puis il continue quand même parce que
bonne partie de son discours la majeure
partie a été consacrée à une véritable
réquisitoire contre l'Occident
néocolonial qui veut imposer son modèle
de société et plus particulièrement un
discours très très hostile vis-à-vis des
États-Unis même sur le la question de
l'arme nucléaire en disant nous accuse
de vouloir utiliser l'arme nucléaire
mais le seul pays qui a jamais utilisé
cette arme ce sont les États-Unis ce qui
fait actuellement est vrai y compris
aussi les armes chimiques il a rappelé
même le napalm utilisé par les
Américains au Vietnam il y a toujours si
vous voulez un peu ce pourquoi parce que
dire ce complexe en fait de Poutine
parce qu'il a fait beaucoup de rappels
historiques et on comprend on creux que
si dans les années 90 l'Occident est
notamment les États-Unis avaient traité
différemment la Russie l'avait traité
d'égal à égal en fait c'est le grand
rêve de la livres protéine c'est que les
États-Unis traitent la Russie sur comme
une grande puissance et sur un pied
d'égalité puisqu'il ne le font pas et
bien il part en guerre contre eux c'est
un combat de valeurs c'est un combat de
civilisation lui est persuadé d'être
visiblement dans son bon droit et
évidemment en face on pense exactement
la même chose ce qui est relativement
inquiétant
et à ça si on ajoute à ça pardon les les
dernières les derniers attentats là sur
les gazoducs c'est doublement inquiétant
parce que ça veut dire que si on admet
que ce sont très probablement les Russes
évidemment qui ont qui ont commis ces
attentats le message envoyé au pays
européens et occidentaux plus
généralement c'est on peut vous frapper
sur vos infrastructures sur votre façon
de vivre y compris au quotidien sur vos
énergies où on veut quand on veut